hey guys it's Pete peppers here and we
got some good news today scrubby dubby
saga came out on mobile so it's on
Facebook and mobile and they made a lot
of a lot of changes to make it really
playable and really fun so I think it'll
be a popular title I'm going to play
through a little bit and explain some of
the different things and hope you guys
will like it as much as we do all right
so one goal we got is collecting and you
know the big thing with this game
compared to the other games you already
know is it's a slider we slide the
pieces together instead of swiping them
you know switching them from with each
other so all we're going to do is just
follow the thing here but see that that
that match will take the ones that you
matched off and it'll drop a couple into
place and we're just collecting as many
as we need
so obviously it's also got specials and
things that you'll want to set up this
tiny board it's not real easy so just go
ahead and finish it off but one thing I
noticed is the graphics are really hot
now they're really super nice and
dynamic which if you go back to our very
first videos and we made about this and
see that that's really they really
raised the bar on that and that's always
good to see and they didn't have any new
levels now but we still have if you're
just starting out there's 180 to play so
that's that's cool
you can see the different types of
levels here that were one with the hippo
is to collect the collection ones the
moment the
alligator or crocodile is two friends
and this is kind of cool because they
actually load up your friends Facebook
photos into the box so it's kind of cool
to be able to collect them so it's
another just slide them make three
colors together you can see the sliding
takes a little bit of time to get used
to but it's um it's it's pretty
intuitive
whenever you slide the difference
between sliding and swiping is is when
you slide the whole row moves so you
know it's a different thought process as
far as planning things out but um after
the first you know ten or fifteen levels
you'll have a pretty solid idea of how
that works without too much
another one is foam this is similar to
you know a blocker level and say candy
crush or something we make the matches
on top of it it disappears and we have
to clear it all before we run out of
moves
got a little match five over here which
is always cool actually I guess it was
going to match five but these are line
glasses and whole rail out if you can
also come up combo this together
obviously so we'll see if we can't do
that somewhere
that was kind of miss click there I was
trying to so you know like here we can
make alarm blasts and then they can make
another one down here now let's see good
very becomes a plus it'll go both
directions instead of just one we'll
make another one those right here too
and then we can just finish it off by
making another line blasts right there
so the foam is free familiar roads in
the conic of sliding so you got to keep
that in mind whenever you're playing
this one and let's see what else kind of
talked about some of the matches you
know some of the combos and things they
took out right now they took out the
plankton levels hopefully they'll bring
those back in I actually like those
those are kind of like jelly levels and
the other I guess maybe they thought
they were too complicated to be in the
early levels so I'll also be updating my
my level index today because we'll need
to take those out but all the hopefully
by the end of the day I'll have all
everything updated in our level index
we've been playing this game for months
and so we had all 180 levels down a
while ago and we'll have them updated to
that we have them all again so that you
don't have to look anywhere beyond our
channel for videos of all of them so the
pearls are similar to like eggs or
something in farm heroes where their
clothes at first so you have to match
three of the closed ones there's a match
five for us you see that makes a bomb
that will do a square but yeah you have
to open up the the pearls first you can
see the counter up here for how many we
need to get and once they're open then
like I said you can
match the open once together and clear
them and collect them all right so I'd
like to alright so this is um this is
this where I'll show you what this does
that explodes everything in the 3x3
square and then we have a one here and
we'll match it with the lines and now it
becomes a wide line blaster so this will
finish off the level because it's going
to take out three rows in both
directions so that's a powerful one
the other ones are I guess I'll just
show them to you what I'll do here is
I'll pause it and then open it back up
after I get these other methods okay so
here I have two of these square kind of
like the burst boosters and I'm going to
match them together to make a combo
which is depending on what you're
playing this is one of the better ones I
showed you the line blast it goes either
way it can be horizontal or vertical so
that can be helpful in certain
situations and this one can be this will
give us like sort of like the striped
arming the rat plus rap match Oh like
it'll hit five squares so we'll drop
that down the blockers got a new look
and I also noticed that the whenever
there's trapped that got a new book to
you so this is our double blast here you
can see it takes out a really big big
spot nice improvement with the graphics
there
and those are the major those are the
major ones depending on what you're
doing it'll be like a you know it'll
depend on whether you want to what kind
of combo you wanna use but most of the
time you're going to want to most of the
time you're going to want to make a
combo unless you can do something right
away or you have a low number of moves
so like I said there's 180 levels we'll
get our list updated so we have the most
up-to-date version of all of them it's
going to be like the third or fourth
time we did that but hey you know as as
long as they get it right you know
obviously we're happy to see a new game
come out hope you like it I'll have the
link to the level index underneath the
video so make sure you check that out if
you are stuck on a level and I'll be
making plenty of new videos as soon as
new games come out so make sure you
subscribe to our Channel hope you like
scrubby join us in our group and we'll
talk to you later